I wish them the very best Alex Rodriguez
has few but kind words for his ex
Jennifer Lopez with Jennifer
um look it was it was a good experience
during a sit-down interview with CNN's
Chris Wallace A-Rod was asked Point
Blank his thoughts on JLo moving on with
Ben Affleck shortly after the former
couple called off their engagement does
it bother you that within days after you
broke up that she was back to seeing Ben
Affleck and that she ended up getting
married to him not you his response
short but sweet with Jennifer
um look it was it was a good experience
and I wish her and the children who are
smart and beautiful and wonderful I wish
them the very best
that's it that's it e-rod and JLo began
dating in 2017 but split four years
later ultimately ending their two-year
engagement at the time they released a
joint statement to ET quote we have
realized we are better as friends and
look forward to remaining stuff I'm so
grateful for it I mean I had uh five
years of of an incredible life and and
partnership and also with my daughters
we learned so much and now we have an
opportunity to take that and move
forward
and as we know Jen moved on too she
rekindled her romance with Ben whom she
was previously engaged to in 2002.
Ben popped the question again in April
and they tied the knot in July okay so
lucky it's not often you get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
so JLo's off the market what about A-Rod
does he see himself exchanging vows
Someday I'm at a point in my life that
I'm actually doing all the things I love
to do when asked about his long list of
famous exes including Madonna Cameron
Diaz and Kate Hudson he had this to say
do you think that your good husband
material or do you think honestly
that you just like the chase I think
pre-suspension if you ask me what's
winning look like I would have said big
contracts home runs World Series you
know nice cars women
post suspension I look at more the team
building being a great father being a
son being a friend
High character loyalty all those things
so in my 20s early 30s probably not the
best I think I'm going to make a
wonderful partner or husband and father
post suspension because of the Lessons
Learned of my biggest mistakes
that suspension he mentioned yeah it
came as a result of his steroid scandal
in 2014 when the MLB accused him of
violating the League's
performance-enhancing drugs policy his
penalty sitting out the entire season I
mentioned when I was 15 years old and
I think Sports illustrator called me a
top player in the country
and
at that time I was Alex Rodriguez
and then somewhere along the way at 24 I
get 250 million dollar contract and
probably in Texas I lost my way a little
bit and I became A-Rod and I think after
the suspension I've worked myself
through a lot of therapy and a lot of
work to Alex Rodriguez
foreign